cats dogs and a super powered guinea pig
dwayne johnson's latest team up with
kevin hart looks like a wild addition to
the dc motion picture cannon you need to
watch this before you see dc league of
super pets
dc league of super beds has been in
development since at least 2018 when
warner brothers revealed that they hired
lego batman writer jared stern to write
and direct a league of super pets the
next year sam levine and patty hicks
were signed on to work as co-director
and producer the movie received an
initial release date of may 21 2021
unfortunately things didn't go as
planned though the timing may seem
appropriate the chances that dc league
of super pets was delayed due to kobit
19 a low warner brothers decided to
delay the film in may 2019. unless the
people at warner brothers are fortune
tellers there was probably some other
unrevealed hiccup that prompted the
delay that's hardly matters because
league of super bets now has a release
date of july 29th 2022
thanks to the official synopsis of dc
league of super bets and its trailers
we've learned a lot about the plot it
looks like superman and the rest of the
justice league are kidnapped leaving
crypto and his new friends to rescue
them ace will lead the team of shelter
pets who have found new powers thanks
for mysterious surge from an orange
kryptonite gem krypto also loses his
super dog powers leaving him powerless
like his owner he is just as susceptible
to green kryptonite as superman so he'll
have to find a way to fight alongside
his new buddies after being reduced to
just a normal dog his positivity and
fearlessness keep his mind strong and
will help him lead the new team will
they be able to defeat the orange
kryptonite equipped lulu you'll have to
see the movie for yourself to find out
dwayne johnson is leading the charge on
dc league of super pets as crypto the
super dog crypto is a faithful dog of
superman and first appeared in adventure
comics issue 210 in 1955. the family dog
in the l household crypto was used as a
test subject to send the rocket to earth
as carl's parents needed to make sure
they could land a rocket on the planet
with their son aboard unfortunately
crypto's rocket goes off course but the
ship eventually writes itself and kal-el
lands on earth and sends off a signal
just like his owner crypto has super
strength the power of flight x-ray
vision and freeze breath unfortunately
he'll be stripped of all these abilities
in the movie leaving him like every
other dog on the street this marks a
second dc project for johnson in 2022
who is set to debut as black adam on
october 21st johnson wrapped his
voiceover role in september 2021 and
said the animated film would be
incredible he's also lovingly nicknamed
his character bach kent the former
wrestlers production company seven bucks
production is also behind the film
the dwayne johnson kevin hart duo is
back as the latter joins dc league of
super pets as ace the baton ace is a
companion of you guessed it batman the
crime-fighting pub first appeared in
batman issue 92 in 1955.
much like crypto and the other pet
sidekicks in the cast ace debuted in the
original dc comics but is mostly known
for his time in the animated short
series dc super pets in the film ace
also boasts super dog strength which he
appears to have acquired when a lab he's
being held in is hit with a surge of
energy that comes from orange kryptonite
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right when promoting
dc league of super pets on his instagram
hart said he was excited to be back on
the big screen with his longtime
colleague johnson before the animated
film the actor starred in four films
together hobbs and shaw central
intelligence jumanji the next level and
jumanji welcome to the jungle johnson
revealed in a dc league of super bets
featurette that one of his favorite
things about the film is crypto and
ace's relationship which he says very
much mirrors his real life friendship
with heart
russian doll star natasha leon stars in
dc league of super beds as merton the
speedster turtle merton mcsnurtle first
appeared in funny stuff issue 1 but went
by the alias of terrific whatsit the
speedy reptile is a companion of the
earth 508 version of wally west little
merton dresses like a different flesh
though inspired by the golden age
version of the character jay garrick he
sports lightning bolts on his boots and
helmets but the dc league of super bet's
film showcases the turtle in just his
shell in the comics merton has granted
superpowers as an experiment to see how
someone 100 honest handles them merton
drops his shell when using his powers
making him look like anything but a
turtle which is why the alias terrific
whatsit was born it doesn't look like
merton will shed his shell based on what
we see in the trailers but anything is
possible the own also revealed merton
has vision problems which can cause
serious issues for someone so fast
also joining the new animated film is
rogue one a star wars story actor diego
luna as chip first appearing in green
lantern vol 2 issue 148 in 1982 chip is
a member of the green lantern corps and
even trained alongside hal jordan luna
revealed that his version of chip is
afraid of basically everything and he
has the annoying tendency to assume that
the worst is going to happen in any
situation chip is very wary of himself
and what he can do and has a hard time
with self-confidence he can manifest
electricity from his tiny little paws
and is not fully in control of his power
at the beginning of the film it will be
up to the rest of the super bets to
guide chip and help him control his
powers and believe in himself
the last of the super pets is pb a pig
voice by saturday night live alum
vanessa bayer not every character in dc
league of super beds has pulled from the
comics and pb is a brand new character
whose initials we're guessing stand for
potbellied according to bayer pb is
obsessed with wonder woman and feels a
connection to the superhero bayer
admires bb for wearing her heart on her
sleeve and being extremely positive as
with some of the other pets it looks
like pb obtains her powers from the
explosion at a lab where she and others
are being held in cages her new power
allows her to grow to colossal size pb
can grow as tall as buildings helping
the pets reach new heights and can even
help give them a launch the friendly pig
will be another positive force within
the team mirroring a lot of kryptos
confidence and friendliness
much like pb lulu is a character who was
created just for the new film kate
mckinnon plays villainous lulu in the
upcoming movie and appears to be the
story's antagonist lulu is a hairless
guinea pig who seems to be some sort of
laboratory experiment evident in her ear
tag which reads lv1u lulu is one
powerful rodent who looks to have
telekinetic powers she wears orange
kryptonite around her neck and sports a
cave that seems to be taken from a piece
of superman's costume lulu has a team of
guinea pigs at her command all the fume
look like they've been experimented on
as well mckinnon says lulu is a small
creature who dreams of being something
bigger while her motives are unclear at
this moment lulu seems to take a special
interest in superman and takes him down
with some kryptonite the actress is no
stranger to voice roles playing
characters in films like the angry birds
movie ferdinand and finding dory
while some of the animals in dc league
of super pets will deny that they are
actually pets some still have owners or
humans they are loyal to crypto's owner
is superman who will be voiced by john
krasinski the office alum revealed his
casting on twitter noting that he always
wanted to do a team-up movie with dwayne
johnson in the new film superman will be
in boatloads of trouble thanks to lulu
and crypto will recruit his new pals to
help him rescue the owner he loves so
much voicing ace's human sidekick is
keanu reeves as batman reeves joined the
warner brothers film a year ago but
exactly who he was playing was revealed
much later in the second trailer for the
film darshan polanco of oranges and new
black fame will also voice the green
lantern jessica cruz while lulu is a big
bad in the film there will also be a
human who's not to be trusted mark maron
will voice lex luthor superman's
longtime nemesis whether lulu and lex
work together is also currently unknown
well well well
if it isn't the justice league while a
lot of actors and their roles in dc
league of super bets have been revealed
to the world there are quite a few
characters who remain a mystery attached
to the film and voice roles are thomas
middleditch ben schwartz and jamila
jamel we'll have to wait and see which
heroes these actors portray as a release
date for the movie gets closer
several trailers have been released for
dc league of super pets two of which put
crypto front and center the lovable
canine is on a quest to save superman
who has been rendered powerless thanks
to lulu as mentioned all the pets except
for crypto are being held in some type
of shelter when orange kryptonite drops
into their room and grants them all very
different powers this looks like it
might be the same gem that lulu wears
around her neck meaning she might have
been granted those powers at the same
time but was able to escape with the
kryptonite the trailers also introduced
a villainous cat whose name has not been
disclosed this cat can shoot rockets out
of its tail and looks to be a worthy
adversary to the super pets a third
special trailer specifically focuses on
batman and ace and how their partnership
comes to be as a child my family was
taken from me as a puppy i was taken
from my family it looks like the two
don't know each other before the film
and connect on their very similar paths
this third trailer also reveals that we
will definitely see the batmobile in dc
league of super pets and there's also
mention of alfred robin commissioner
gordon and whoever morgan freeman played
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
dc league of super pets are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you